so many people look to you as example of
this this person that can write such
amazing scripts you you're so incredible
with dialog and with creating scenes and
you recently taught a master class and I
thought oh this is this is gonna be
fantastic and a lot of people thought
yes Aaron Sorkin and master class he's
gonna tell us all the secrets and a part
of the master class were your opinions
on pop-tarts and I had I just have to
say as someone I was think like that is
not why I tuned in to hear your opinions
on pop-tarts and your very strong
opinions but I have I do have very
strong opinions about pop-tarts I don't
want to be divisive on your show I'm
there's too much of that in late-night
and you know there is I'm worried about
angering people but you know what I
should speak my truth so here it is
[Music]
unfrosted untoasted blueberry strawberry
those are the only real pop-tarts the
others are these candy - either that
strawberry blueberry untoasted on
frosted okay if you want to be a
professional writer I think this
interview is over I think I've never
disagreed with anybody more about
anything in my life
I like mine not only frosted but with
the sprinkly stuff on them I like and I
like and I like a chocolate one too if a
chocolate one with a glass of milk with
the sprinkles on top you tell me that's
a bad pop these aren't subjective
choices okay this is just right or wrong
and I'm right I you're not welcome here
again that's all I can say right now I
was a fan I now wish you ill in here we
don't go see Molly's game yeah yeah game
everybody until this guy wise
[Applause]
you